Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute
Papers with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Whenever we take a photo, we capture a
piece of reality from one viewpoint. Or,
if we have multiple cameras on our smartphone, a
few viewpoints at most. In an earlier episode, we
explored how to upgrade these to 3D photos, where
we could we could kind of look behind the person.
I am saying kind of, because what we see
here is not reality, this is statistical data
that is filled in by an algorithm to match
its surroundings, which we refer to as image
inpainting. So strictly speaking, it is likely
information, but not necessarily true information,
and also, we can recognize the synthetic parts
of the image as they are significantly blurrier.
So the question naturally arises in the mind
of the curious Scholar, how about actually
looking behind the person. Is that somehow
possible or is that still science fiction?
Well, hold on to your papers,
because this technique shows us
the images of the future by sticking a
bunch of cameras onto a spherical shell,
and when we capture a video, it will see…something
like this. And the goal is to untangle this mess
and we’re not done yet, we also need to
reconstruct the geometry of the scene
as if the video was captured from many different
viewpoints at the same time. Absolutely amazing.
And yes, this means that we can change
our viewpoint while the video is running.
Since it is doing the reconstruction in layers,
we know how far each object is in these scenes,
enabling us to rotate these sparks and
flames and look at them in 3D. Yum.
Now, I am a light transport researcher by
trade, so I hope you can tell that I am very
happy about these beautiful volumetric
effects, but I would also love to know
how it deals with reflective surfaces. Let’s see
together…look at the reflections in the sand here,
and I’ll add a lot of camera movement and
wow…this thing works. It really works,
and it does not break a sweat even if
we try a more reflective surface…or
an even more reflective surface! This
is as reflective as it gets I’m afraid,
and we still get a consistent and
crisp image in the mirror. Bravo!
Alright, let’s get a little more
greedy, what about seeing through
thin fences…that is quite a challenge.
And…look at the tail wags there. This is still
a touch blurrier here and there,
but overall, very impressive.
So what do we do with a video like this?
Well, we can use our mouse to look around
within the photo in our web browser,
you can try this yourself right now
by clicking on the paper in the video description.
Make sure to follow the instructions if you do.
Or we can make the viewing experience even more
immersive with a head-mounted display, where,
of course, the image will follow wherever
we turn our head. Both of these truly feel
like entering a photograph and getting
a feel of the room therein. Loving it.
Now, since there is a lot of information in these
Light Field Videos, it also needs a powerful
internet connection to relay them. Even when using
H.265, a powerful video compression standard,
we are talking in the order of hundreds of
megabits. It is like streaming several videos in
4k resolution at the same time. Compression helps,
however, we also have to make sure that we don’t
compress too much, so that compression artifacts
don’t eat the content behind thin geometry,
or at least, not too much. I bet this will
be an interesting topic for a followup paper,
so make sure to subscribe and hit the
bell icon to not miss it when it appears.
And for now, more practical light field photos and
videos will be available that allow us to almost
feel like we are really in the room with the
subjects of the videos. What a time to be alive!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!